je proposerai que toute personne majeure
en phase avancée ou terminale incurable
d'une maladie provoquant une souffrance
physique ou psychique insupportable
écrit que ne peut plus être apaisée
puisse demander dans des conditions
précises et sous contrôle de plusieurs
médecins à bénéficier d'une assistance
médicale pour vivre sa vie la dignité
jusqu'à la fin a pris le mariage pour
tous c'est l'une des réformes de société
sur laquelle on attendait françois
hollande le droit à une aide active à
mourir en proposant une assistance
médicale pour vivre sa vie dans la
dignité jusqu'à la fin le candidat
hollande a délibérément choisi une
formulation ambiguë où jamais il ne
prononce le mot euthanasie des mots à la
loi le président avance avec prudence
après deux ans de concertation nationale
il confie la rédaction d'une proposition
de loi à deux députés alain claeys et
jean leonetti une proposition de loi
consensuelle qui reprend et précise la
première loi leonetti de 2005
sans aller jusqu'à l'euthanasie selon un
sondage pourtant 90 % des français y
sont favorables pour les personnes en
fin de vie
ce nouveau texte répond t-il vraiment
aux attentes des français
va t'il assez loin de la promesse de
campagne à la loi le consensus sera
difficile à trouver
pourquoi le nouveau texte a bien parce
que malheureusement dans la pratique on
constate encore quand meurt mal en
france
amber mal avec deux revendications
légitimes de nos concitoyens c'est je ne
suis pas entendu en fin de vie et on
continue à souffrir dans les derniers
jours et dernières heures de la vie
bonjour comment ça va ce matin oui les
douleurs ici là où les synthés un petit
peu quand même
à 78 ans c'est la deuxième fois qu'on
gèle et ton soins palliatifs au chu de
montpellier
atteinte d'un cancer incurable elle
c'est sa mort proche
son seul souhait finir ses jours sans
souffrir en main propre au monde selon
un avis je sais que je mourrais mais je
ne veux pas mourir l'un en souffrent
voilà je sais que je vais mourir une de
ces jours parce que sans ça n'est au
point où un aérosol palliatifs pour la
libérer tous à ce qu'il n'y a pas autre
chose grand chose à faire mais on n'a
pas la souffrance
moi je comprends les gens qui souffrent
et qui jette sous le règne de ce cd
souffrance qu'on peut pas tenir quand on
fait les soins palliatifs après au
contraire ça ça soulage ça ça guérit pas
mais ça enlève la douleur moi c'est ce
que je veux je veux mourir sans souffrir
voilà pour soulager les souffrances dans
ce centre de soins palliatifs on utilise
des techniques à la pointe comme la
sédation une sorte d' anesthésie plus ou
moins profondes pour apaiser le patient
cette technique sédation c'est quand on
est en échec
effectivement sur un symptôme parc
vraiment insupportable pour le patient
donc avec certains médicaments notamment
le midazolam
on l'utilisent pour entraîner un sommeil
d'une profondeur qui va dépendre du
patient des patients préfèrent rester un
petit peu éveillées d'autres qui ne
veulent pas être du tout réveiller
donc ça on adapte la dose et qu'on peut
faire de manière transitoire par exemple
prendre symptômes communs le disney qui
peut être parfois transitoire ou pour
de manière on peut également faire cette
citation de manière continue si le
patient effectivement ne désire plus que
tout autre la loi de 2015 veut
démocratiser la sédation profonde et
continue
c'est à dire l'endormissement profond du
patient dont la mort est imminente pour
lui éviter de souffrir lors de ses
dernières heures c'est quand l'heure on
veut vraiment c'est endormir le patient
pour pas qu'ils qu'ils subissent ce qui
est en train de vivre mais on ne veut
pas précipiter sa mort simplement il
faut qu'il soit quand même un peu plus
serein par rapport à ce qu'il est en
train de vivre
on met des fois des sédation comme ça
sur des choses cataclysmique on voit et
ça on a on a eu à le faire il n'y a pas
très longtemps
un patient qui s'est vidée de son sens
et qui le voyait qu'ils étaient
conscients et c'est terrible est bon
donc là on l'a endormi et il est parti
non pas de notre endormissement mais du
fait qu'il était en train de se vider
sur d'une hémorragie sur lequel on
pouvait pas intervenir si vous voulez
si dans ce genre d'unités spécialisées
les médecins maîtrise technique
ce n'est pas le cas dans d'autres
services hospitaliers comme aux urgences
ou dans les services d'oncologie où le
taux de mortalité est élevée la sédation
profonde et continue y est peu utilisée
l'objectif de la loi est donc de la
généraliser ce droit qu'on appelle le
droit à la sédation en phase terminale
est un droit qui paraît légitime
aujourd'hui c'est un devoir des médecins
de le mettre en place ce n'est pas le
cas malheureusement
donc 15 à 20 % des cas eh bien il faut
que ça devienne un droit et au peut-être
que la vraie modification de la loi
c'est de dire avant c'était un devoir de
la société est un devoir d du corps
médical et des soignants de faire en
sorte qu'on ne souffre pas en fin de vie
et bien désormais
ça devient un droit du malade de ne pas
souffrir lorsque la mort approche et que
les médicaments habituels n'arrivait pas
à calmer la souffrance
la nouvelle loi précisent les cas où
cette sédation profonde et continue doit
s'appliquer premier cas le patient est
conscient il est atteint d'une affection
grave et incurable
son pronostic vital est engagé et
l'arrêt des traitements va provoquer sa
mort à court terme
autre possibilité le patient est
inconscient pour éviter l'acharnement
thérapeutique le médecin décide
d'arrêter les traitements
il peut dans ce cas aussi demandé une
sédation profonde et continue en
encadrant la sédation profonde et
continue les auteurs de la loi voulait
être consensuel
mais au sénat cette proposition va
cristalliser les oppositions autour de
la question de l'euthanasie
trois camps vont s'affronter
il ya d'un côté les rapporteurs de la
proposition du texte et le gouvernement
ils vont soutenir l'idée d'une sédation
profonde et continue ce texte et ce et
pour ceux qui vont mourir pas pour ceux
qui veulent mourir ce qui élimine très
clairement le débat sur l'euthanasie et
le suicide assisté
non pas que ce débat ne soit pas
important voire capital mais quelque
part ce n'était pas l'esprit de la loi
sur laquelle nous discutions d'autres
une partie des sénateurs républicains
s'opposent à toute évolution juridique
pour le texte va trop loin
en inscrivant la sédation profonde et
continue dans la loi le législateur
proposerait en réalité une euthanasie
déguisé la sédation profonde continue
jusqu'au décès vous voyez bien on liait
la sédation et le dessin et là ça nous a
apparu pas pour moi seulement mais pour
un certain nombre d'entre nous comme
quelque chose qui sortait du dispositif
consensuelle de la loi léonetti et qu'il
y ait le décès à l'acte de ces nations
donc on engageait en s'engageant sur
dans l'engrenage
sur le chemin du suicide assisté et
l'euthanasie
enfin il y a les sénateurs qui estime
que cette sédation profonde et continue
n'est pas suffisante
ils veulent inscrire dans la loi le
droit à l'euthanasie
nous voulions répondre à deux demandes
différentes qui sont de nature
différente
d'une part le droit un suicide
médicalement assisté c'est à dire qu'on
abrège la fin de vie un peu avant le
terme qui est imminent et puis donc
c'est le fils y est d'assister et puis
d'autre part il ya des personnes qui
réclament lorsqu'elles sont dans un état
désespéré la possibilité d'une
euthanasie
premier affrontement en séance autour de
l'article 3 sur la sédation profonde et
continue
les opposants à cette pratique lance
l'offensive contre les rapporteurs du
texte
depuis le départ un certain nombre
d'entre nous pensons que la loi les deux
petits se suffisait à elle-même et que
et que la loi actuelle qui est pour
certains prolongement ou un éclairage
n'est pas un prolongement ou un
éclairage
c'est une rupture il est incontestable
cet article 3 est la porte ouverte à une
euthanasie que vous ne voulez pas des
nommés comme tel les sénateurs proposent
d'enlever du texte l'expression continue
jusqu'au décès pour éviter tout amalgame
avec l'euthanasie
pour alain milon le président de la
commission des affaires sociales qui est
aussi médecin
c'est un coup porté au principe même de
la loi cette proposition de loi ne tue
pas on n'est pas là pour tuer on n'est
pas là pour faire de ta nazis on est là
pour accompagner des malades en fin de
vie
alors la proposition que nous fait notre
collègue de lège sur le fait de mettre
une sédation profonde et de supprimer
continue jusqu'au décès ok pourquoi pas
la sédation n'est pas continue elles
tiennent est pas continuer les dix
continuent et services continue ça vient
qu'on doit l'arrêter de temps en temps
pourquoi continue plaçons-nous quand
même d'un la vraie vie si j'ose dire
comment imaginer que chez ces patients
qui souffrent atrocement on va
interrompre la sédation pour dialoguer
avec eux sur l'opportunité de quoi de
continuer c est impensable et vraiment
ceux qui ont porté cet amendement sont
très éloignées de la vraie vie c'est le
cas de le dire je vais mettre aux voix
cet amendement 59 rectifié qui est pour
l'amendement est adopté une partie des
républicains obtient gain de cause le
mot continue est retirée du texte
la séance est suspendue dans les
couloirs les esprits s'échauffent entre
les deux camps réparer ça a été ils ont
de manière un peu habile sans doute par
certains
d'où vouloir faire comprendre que la
sédation profonde et continue était très
proche de l'euthanasie
or ce n'est pas vrai puisque
l'euthanasie elle est faite un moment
avant qu'on soit dans cette situation là
c'est à dire avant que la personne soit
vraiment en fin de vie c'est à dire avec
une espérance de vie à court terme et à
ne supportant plus les souffrances
qu'elle subit donc ça n'est pas du tout
une euthanasie
c'est simplement une possibilité d'aider
à mourir sans avoir les souffrances
l'autre offensive contre le texte
viendra cette fois des pros et en asie
huit sénateurs de toutes tendances
politiques réunis autour de jean luc
romero président de la dmd une
association pro euthanasie convoque la
presse
il y a dans chaque groupe des
parlementaires ont déposé des
amendements allant dans le sens de ce
que souhaitent de ce que souhaite la dmd
c'est à dire qu'il y ait enfin une loi
qui permette à chacun de choisir c'est
pas une loi spécialement pour
l'euthanasie une loi qui permette de
comment dire de choisir
ils comptent inscrire dans le texte un
droit à une aide active à mourir
c'était important justement que certains
sénateurs et de toutes tendances c'est
ça qui était important puisse dire que
eux ils souhaitaient clairement qu'on
aille à la légalisation de l'euthanasie
et du suicide assisté comme les français
le demandent dans tous les sondages
depuis vingt ou trente ans le soir même
en séance
les huit sénateur dépose tous un
amendement pour légaliser l'euthanasie
cet amendement propose d'instaurer un
droit à bénéficier d'une véritable aide
active à mourir pour les personnes
majeures
il répond à une très forte demande de la
population
il vise à instaurer l'assistance
médicalisée active à mourir dans des
conditions strictes
chacun doit se voir ainsi reconnaître le
droit d'aborder sa fin de vie dans le
respect des principes de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité
des amendements rejetés mais l'objectif
est atteint
le débat sur l'euthanasie a été mis sur
la table
nous voulions poser ce débat c'est à
dire d'une loi qui irait plus loin
donc l'idée était d'expliquer pourquoi
cette loi nous semblait trop timide et
pourquoi nous voulions aller plus loin
et pourquoi du coup nous avons tous
déposé un amendement très très voisin
pour essayer d'avancer alors l'ambiguïté
qu'il faudrait lever c'est que ce texte
n'était pas fait pour ceux qui sont en
fin de vie et qui veulent mourir
ce texte a été fait pour les malades en
fin de vie qui vont mourir donc
évidemment ce texte ne recouvrait que
très imparfaitement les demandes que
nous avions
l'autre point de clivage du texte ce
sont les directives anticipées
un document où l'on inscrit ce que l'on
souhaite pour sa fin de vie
edit a écrit les siennes elle est
bénévole au centre d'écouté de la dmd
l'association au droit à mourir dans la
dignité
compte tenu de mon âge je refuse toute
réanimation alimentation forcée
artificielle lorsque la mort paraît
inévitable mettre sur papier ce qu'elle
veut pour sa fin de vie
une évidence pour elle après la mort
d'une de ses amies
en 1996 j'ai assisté à la mort
terrifiante d'une amie qui avait une
sclérose latérale amyotrophique la
maladie de charcot et qui mouraient dans
des conditions d'étouffement qui n'en
finissait plus j'ai appelé le docteur
c'était un dimanche on a fait venir
sos médecins et j'ai dit aux médecins
écouter elle est en fin de vie regarde
est en train de mourir si tout forme du
oui elle va mourir idiot et va mourir
vili mes docteurs fait quelque chose
pour que ça aille plus vite
il m'a répondu mais madame je ne peux
rien faire d'ailleurs elle n'a rien
demandé et je ne peux rien faire alors
ça m'a fait beaucoup réfléchir et j'ai
très vite rédigé des directives de
volonté comme édite aujourd'hui il n'y a
que 2 5% des français qui ont rédigé
leurs directives anticipées
sophie j'ai eu la visite ce matin du nos
adhérentes et elle est venue porter ces
directives anticipées
alors chers pour sophie responsable des
directives à la dmd si aussi peu de gens
les ont écrite c'est qu'elles sont
méconnus mais pas seulement
il s'agit de confronter cette idée de
mort de déchéance de de fin de vie c'est
pas enfin en tant qu'être humain on n'a
pas envie de confronter ça n'est ce pas
ensuite souvent les personnes ne savent
pas parler de leur famille
aujourd'hui les directives anticipées ne
s'impose pas aux médecins
elles peuvent être rédigée sur papier
libre et sont valables trois ans la loi
de 2015 prévoit de les rendre
contraignante pour le médecin de créer
un modèle officiel qui sera intégré dans
un registre national et leur validité ne
sera plus limité au sénat pas de
rassemblements non plus sur les
directives anticipées
un bras de fer s'engage entre les
défenseurs du texte et le noyau dur des
sénateurs les républicains ces derniers
estiment que le dispositif va trop loin
ils vont de nouveau réussir un coup de
force et faire enlever du texte le
caractère contraignant des directives
anticipées
par conséquent nous proposons une autre
rédaction qui indique le médecin prend
en compte les directives anticipées mais
qu'elle ne s'impose pas à lui c'est
effectivement une différence majeure
entre nous le médecin est là pour
prendre en compte les directives
anticipées mais il doit garder son
appréciation et son jugement la question
ces directives
c'était doivent-elles engagé les
médecins ou pas doit-on laisser une
marge de manoeuvre aux médecins qui peut
aussi avoir des éléments d'appréciation
de façon collégiale notamment
pour marisol touraine la ministre de la
santé
cette nouvelle manoeuvre vise surtout à
vider la loi de son sens se donne un
avis défavorable parce que demander quel
directives anticipées ne s'impose pas au
médecin et ne s'inscrit pas là non plus
dans la perspective porté par cette
proposition de loi
merci madame la ministre qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est adopté
s'il y a déjà anticipé l d'europe à
notre avis elles doivent être appliquées
par le médecin qui est présent alors que
la tels que c'est on retourne comme
auparavant et ça veut dire qu'elles ne
sont pas opposables donc le médecin peut
faire ce qu'il veut
directives anticipées non contraignante
sédation profonde mais non continue le
texte qui devait être celui du consensus
a été vidé de son contenu détricoté par
un petit groupe de sénateurs
républicains mobilisés et qui a su
donner de la voix face à la commission
et au gouvernement lao n'est
effectivement dans un texte qui s'est
éloigné progressivement non seulement du
texte 2015 mais qui en partie a remis en
cause le texte de 2005
donc je crois que la première des choses
à faire c'est s'appuyer sur le texte
2005 dans tout le monde y compris au
sénat et y compris les adversaires de la
loi 2015 disent qu'elle est très bien
donc ne toucheront pas la loi de 2005
une dernière question va être débattue
celle du droit d'accès aux soins
palliatifs
chaque année en france ils ne sont que
cent mille personnes à en bénéficier
pourtant les besoins sont trois fois
plus importants
bonjour vous ça va ça veut dire quoi que
sa maman
les murs de cette chambre qui rit les
connaît par coeur il est cloué dans son
lit depuis un an on lui a découvert une
maladie orpheline incurable il y a
quatre ans depuis son état se dégrade
pour soulager ses douleurs une équipe de
soins palliatifs vient régulièrement à
son domicile
il me soulage
monsieur avant tout ils sont bien ils
sont toujours là il reste des problèmes
internes à ils sont très bien ils sont
prévues je suis bien entouré comment se
trouve moralement fatima est infirmière
c'est elle qui gère l'équipe de soins
palliatifs à domicile
elle vient voir thierry régulièrement en
fonction de ses besoins
l'occasion pour elle de faire le point
avec les aides soignants sur l'évolution
de l'état de santé de thierry alors
notre rôle c'est d'être en lien avec les
professionnels du domicile de réfléchir
avec eux comment maintenir améliorer
soutenir la présence du patient de chez
lui
des patients hospitalisés chez eux
fatima on suit une quarantaine son
équipe de soins palliatifs est financé
par l' agence régionale de santé
mais clairement elle manque de moyens on
ne peut pas dire que c'est insuffisant
en terme de moyens enfin puisque nous
sommes sur un bassin très important dans
ce jeu graphique très important et nous
couvrons un nombre d'une population de
plus de 620 mille habitants donc on est
une équipe quasiment toutes à temps
partiel et nous avons de plus en plus de
demandes de la part des professionnels
de santé des institutions et des
familles mes mises en ligne par les
professionnels de santé ce qui signifie
que nous sommes de plus en plus
sollicités pour cette aide au maintien à
domicile en france des réseaux à
domicile comme celui de fatima sont
rares la loi leonetti de 2005 devait
pourtant les développer tout comme les
unités de soins palliatifs dans les
hôpitaux
aujourd'hui très inégalitaire sur le
territoire
s'il y en a beaucoup dans les grandes
agglomérations elles ne sont pas
suffisantes dans les zones rurales
idem pour les unités de soins palliatifs
qui se déplace dans les services des
hôpitaux les unités mobiles
un manque criant dénoncée par les
sénateurs les républicains qui demandent
au gouvernement d'inscrire l'égalité
d'accès aux soins palliatifs dans ce
nouveau texte
je pense que ceux qui sont pour ce texte
ceux qui le portent ne peuvent pas ne
pas entendre ce cri le cri des
territoires qui sont injustement traités
avec cette kyrielle de malades qui ne
peuvent pas avoir accès aux soins
palliatifs alors que leur état devrait
leur permettre et qu'ils en souffrent un
des soucis du texte est aujourd' hui et
de demain d'ailleurs c'est que on se
refuse en france avoir une politique
massive d'investissement en matière de
culture palliative en matière de soins
palliatifs
c'est là qu'est le problème est surtout
vous savez que 20 % de nos concitoyens
ont accès à ces soins palliatifs 80% n'y
ont pas accès et ses soins palliatifs
c'est le privilège de quelques
territoires
la plupart de nos territoires n'y ont
pas accès et je considérais avec
d'autres que le problème le plus urgent
c'était pas tellement de faire une
nouvelle loi
c'était d'abord tsy et traiter ces
problèmes très concrets
les rapporteurs et le gouvernement
partage ce constat mais estime que cette
question doit être traitée dans le cadre
du financement de la santé oms ni il
faut développer les soins palliatifs
c'est quand même avant tout un problème
purement financiers et ça ça se décide
dans le plfss ailleurs dans le budget de
financement de la sécurité sociale dont
coop plfss
ce genre d'amendements et apparaissent
çà au contraire est tout à fait d'accord
personnellement j'ai essayé de leur
expliquer et réexpliquer mais ils n'ont
pas voulu suivre au plfss
eh bien nous réclamerons et nous
aspirons les moyens financiers
nécessaires pour que le développement
des soins palliatifs
je fasse sur l'ensemble du territoire
mais l'argument des rapporteurs ne
convainc pas les autres groupes
politiques se rallie aux républicains
alors au risque de surprendre moi je
pense que c'était plutôt bien comme
amendement et il me semblait alors que
je défends une position différente pour
le reste du texte
je me sentais tout à l'heure un petit
peu isolé là dessus je pense que le
préalable c'est les soins palliatifs
pour tous je m'aperçois avec
stupéfaction que ça pose un problème
par le terme d' homme david je vais vous
étonner à mon tour mais je suis sur la
même position que vient de défendre ma
collègue corinne bouchoux la déclaration
d'intention étaient là elles étaient
fermés c'était des soins palliatifs pour
tous sur tout le territoire
s'il suffisait d'inscrire les choses
dans la loi lorsqu'elle doivent aller de
soi pour que les choses se réalisent ce
serait tellement simple j'ai annoncé
tout à l'heure que je présenterai que je
proposerai la semaine prochaine à un
comité de pilotage un plan triennal de
développement des soins palliatifs et
des unités de soins palliatifs dont un
des axes majeurs sera la réduction des
inégalités sur le territoire et pas
simplement entre les territoires
lorsqu'alain classe et moi même avons
remis le rapport au président de la
république sur la proposition de loi
nous avons dit tous les deux que la
priorité des priorités c'était le
développement des soins palliatifs et la
formation des soignants et qu'aucune loi
si parfaite serait-elle celle là
n'étaient pas parfaites comme toutes les
lois humaines
et bien ne peut être efficace s'il n'y a
pas ces deux éléments fin de l'examen du
texte au sénat et fin de partie pour les
rapporteurs et le gouvernement qui sorte
de grand perdant de cette séquence
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que le
travail qui avait été fait par nos trois
rapporteurs
mettez un travail excellent et que ce
travail a été détricoté et si c'était
pour en arriver à la rédaction qui ce
soir se trouve sur la table
il n'était pas nécessaire de proposer un
texte de loi nouveau des rapporteurs
déçus qui estiment leur travail gâché
par quelques sénateurs qu'il qualifie de
conservateurs c'est un texte de
conservateur peut être guidé aussi par
des aides et des arrières-pensées
religieuse quelque peu intégristes j'ai
pas peur de le dire et je trouve que
allez je me lâche la charité chrétienne
c'est pas ça si on commence à
s'invectiver pour dire il y aller parce
que derrière le mot conservatoire en
france pour dire voilà ils méritent pas
d'exister faut pas s'attarder sont et
réactionnaire savez la réaction où est
elle je traite personnes avec des
qualificatifs qui pourrait être
péjoratif qui pourrait déclasser leurs
arguments je pense que l'honneur de ce
genre de débat c'est chacun puisse
essayé d'argumenter sur ses convictions
quelques jours plus tard à l'occasion du
vote solennel sur l'ensemble du texte
les rapporteurs prennent leur revanche
le texte vidé de sa substance article
par article est finalement rejetée par
le sénat
j'ai à la fois d'infini regrets qu'un
consensus qu'un rassemblement ne se soit
pas opérer au sénat comme il s'était
opéré à l'assemblée nationale mais je
suis soulagé que la sagesse de la haute
assemblée elle est amenée à rejeter ce
texte qui va permettre au travail de
reprendre dans des conditions plus
simple à l'assemblée nationale
au jeu des affrontements le sénat sort
perdant en rejetant la proposition de
loi sur la fin de vie dont quelques mois
les députés reprendront l'examen du
texte en seconde lecture
dans sa version initiale